- I mean, you know,
I snatched dudes clearly out the window.
I'm talking big motherfuckers.
Just, you know. Where the money at, man?
Don't play with my ho.
And that itself alone,
man, I'm talking about...
They clear their pockets
so fast, you know.
Because you don't want
me to put my hand on you.
I'm gonna hurt you, bad.
- [Mark] Mm-hm.
All right, Gorilla Joe.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Gorilla Joe, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Los Angeles.
- South Central?
- Concrete Vietnam.
- Mm-hm.
And tell me about your family,
you had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- With my mom.
My dad, fuck him. Fuck him.
Yeah, no filter, fuck him.
- Your dad?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You didn't have a good
relationship with your dad?
- Uh-uh, not at all.
He was never there, it was just my mom.
And you would think, how is he
with the bitches
but he was raised by his mom, you know?
- You ever see your dad?
- Yeah.
I done fought him four times.
- You fought him four times?
- Yeah, I haven't won yet.
Because he slapped me when I was little
and I never forgot that,
I told him I'd fuck him
up when I got older.
So I'm gonna take one more shot at him.
He get me this time,
I'll just leave it alone.
But I don't think he
gonna get me this time.
- [Mark] So you got introduced
to the game at what point?
- Hm?
- You got started.
- Young, man, young. 13, 14.
- [Mark] Who showed you
the ropes? How'd you learn?
- My buddy, a man named Moe,
he'd sit in the garage and, you know,
lace us about the game, you know,
and some of us, we took to it,
some of us, you know, didn't grab it.
Me, I embraced it.
- [Mark] It's been your thing ever since?
- Huh?
- Oh, yeah.
- [Mark] How many years
you been doing this now?
- I'm 55.
- You're 55.
- So 13 to 55.
- [Mark] How many girls you got now?
- 10.
- Working on more.
- [Mark] And your girls will
bring you every dime they make?
- Every penny.
- [Mark] And you provide
security, I'm sure.
- Oh yeah, for sure.
I mean, if they know that
they gorilla black pimp,
if they know they my hos,
they not gonna do nothing to them.
- [Mark] Yeah, I assume
that you have a little,
quite a bit of respect on the street.
- Yeah, I shut them
all down, so, you know.
- [Mark] (laughs) I bet you did.
- They know, don't fuck with his hos.
- [Mark] Yeah, once
they see you in action,
I guess nothing much is gonna happen.
(Joe laughs)
So the game has changed
a lot over the years.
- Yeah.
- How has it affected you?
- Not at all, because
I keep it old school.
I don't adapt to the new
shit, I keep it old school.
Keep it old school, they
can't fuck with you,
because you're living by
the rules of the game.
The people that don't survive is the ones
who try to change the game.
You can't change the game.
- [Mark] What do you
make of all these new,
the tennis shoe pimps,
the gang member pimps
that are out there?
- I mean, it's nothing to
me, I grew up a gangster,
so, you know, I don't worry about them.
They need to be worried about me. Yeah.
- [Mark] And if one of
your girls wants to leave?
- Bye, bitch. There's
plenty more out there.
You don't want a ho
where they feel
that they can't leave,
because that's a whole different game.
That'll get you in trouble,
so bye bitch, bye. Go.
- But you're an imposing-
- I mean, you know,
I'm gonna put my get
down down, but, you know.
- [Mark] Do you ever have
to use fear or intimidation
or even get physical with the girls?
- I'll slap three or
four bitches. (laughs)
With a good one, you
know, you've seen her jaw.
That's 'cause that bitch got out of line.
- [Mark] And do you have kids
of your own? Are you married?
- Yeah, I got kids.
- You raise them?
- Hm?
- You raise your kids?
- Yeah.
- You have boys or girls?
- I got three boys, two girls.
- Two girls.
So if one of your girls wanted to do this.
- Nah.
- What do you say to that?
- I can't knock the game,
man. I can't knock the game.
And if she's a part of it,
that's what she wanted to do anyway.
You know, but I mean to some fathers
it'd be a disappointment or whatever.
I have no feelings, bro.
- [Mark] So love is not
part of the picture.
- Nah, love don't live here,
Jack. Love don't live here.
- It's all about the money.
- M O N E Y.
- You done prison time?
- Hm?
- Have you done prison time?
- Oh, a whole lot.
- [Mark] What kind of
stuff got you in prison?
- Huh?
- What for?
- Murdering, robbery, assault.
You know, I don't do the petty shit.
If I'm gonna go, I'm gonna
go for something, you know.
- [Mark] And you'll have
sex with your girls?
- Hm?
- [Mark] You'll have sex with your girls?
- A couple of them, not all of them.
- [Mark] What about drugs?
Are drugs part of their scene?
- Some of them do drugs,
some of them don't.
- [Mark] And if one of your
girls gets a little headstrong,
gets a little bit out
of line, what do you do?
(Joe claps)
- Just one of them.
- [Mark] What personality traits
do you look for in a girl?
Are there certain types of
girls that are good for this?
- Submissive. That's all, submissive.
See, it's what I lay to them, okay?
And if they don't conform to that,
they don't want to be in my stable.
- [Mark] Yeah, but
there's clearly some girls
that are cut out for this kind of work
and other ones just aren't, right?
- Exactly. Like the one
that was sitting here.
That's a work in progress, you know.
She'd probably be, you know,
kicked out sooner or later.
'Cause I think she's dealing
with some mental issues
that I don't have time for.
- [Mark] But the pimp and
prostitute relationship,
is it based on what these
girls experienced as children
with their fathers, perhaps?
You know, a lot of them
went through child abuse, sexual abuse.
- Well, a lot of them, but a lot of them,
they're just here for
dollars like we do, you know.
If they do the right thing,
they know the right thing
gonna be done to them.
- [Mark] And what are you
proudest of in your life?
What are you proudest of?
- Pimp of the year, man.
- You were pimp of the year?
- Pimp of the year.
- [Mark] In all your years of doing this,
you've been doing this for decades,
what's the craziest thing you've seen
out there on the street?
- The craziest thing I've seen?
- Yeah.
- Regarding?
- [Mark] Just like, you
know, hijinks that happen
on the streets with the
girls, with the tricks.
- I've seen a lot, but if it
ain't in Pimping Joe's circle,
I don't give a fuck about it.
What they doing, I don't care.
Now you ask me the craziest shit
I ever did or seen or I did.
- [Mark] Tell me the
craziest thing you've done.
- I mean, you know.
I done snatched dudes
clearly out the window.
I'm talking big motherfuckers.
Just, you know. Where the money at, man?
Don't play with my ho.
And that itself alone,
man, I'm talking about...
They clear their pockets
so fast, you know.
Because you don't want me
to put my hands on you.
'Cause I'm gonna hurt you, bad.
- [Mark] What's the most
extreme you've had to get
with one of your girls?
- The most extreme with one of them?
- Yeah.
- Just a slap.
One slap, I mean, this
motherfucker right here,
this motherfucker hurt.
It's like getting slapped with bricks.
And they don't want, you see that girl?
- That was you.
- Yeah. They don't like that.
You see how submissive she was today.
Kissing me on the hand and shit.
There's no one kissing my hand.
- [Mark] Being a gorilla pimp
is a very different style than-
- [Joe] The regular pimp.
- [Mark] Yeah, the
stereotypical, well-dressed.
- Yeah.
- You're not flashy.
- [Joe] No, I don't do that.
That way no attention, you know, is on me.
I look like a regular Joe
walking down the street.
But there's so much up in here. (laughs)
- [Mark] But what attracts a girl
to this arrangement that you have is-
- [Joe] Because they know
they're gonna be protected.
- [Mark] Yeah, but it's
also mind control, it seems.
- [Joe] Well, you know,
I have the gift of gab.
I know what they want to hear
so they feel comfortable.
I know what they need to hear.
- [Mark] Could you ever
imagine yourself switching,
swapping places with the
girls, where you're the one
that's having sex for money
and they're keeping the money?
- [Joe] Negative, negative.
Joe is not for sale.
- [Mark] And it's okay for
you to do that to them,
but there's no way that would-
- [Joe] It would never happen. (laughs)
It would never happen.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- The most important lesson that I learned
is to make sure that ho got your money.
That's the most important lesson.
AOB, all on the bitch.
- [Mark] You ever done
anything with the girls
where they're getting reprimanded,
they're getting disciplined by you?
- Yeah, I cut a bitch's nipple off.
I pulled bitches' pubic hairs out.
I've plucked toenails off.
I mean, stick a broomstick in their ass.
How much more extreme
do you want me to get?
- [Mark] That's pretty extreme.
That would get me to stay in line.
(Joe laughs)
- I mean, you know, but...
Some of them...
I mean, it's really how angry they get me
is how extreme that shit gonna be.
How extreme they're charging on me. Yeah.
- [Mark] Okay, so Joe, here we are,
the day after our previous interview.
- Yeah.
- With a couple of your girls.
- Who do we have here?
- I'm Red.
- Red, and?
What is your name?
- Monique.
So ladies, tell me what
it's like to work with Joe.
- It's interesting.
- Mean.
- [Mark] Is he as mean as he looks?
- Sometimes.
- Meaner.
- Meaner?
- Sometimes.
- [Mark] I mean there's different
styles to this game right?
You could've chosen a pimp that maybe was
a little more suave and
debonair, but you chose somebody
who's probably the
biggest thug on Figueroa.
- 'Cause he's grounded.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] He's grounded?
- Grounded means he's all natural.
Not trying to be anything else but him.
- [Mark] But nobody says no
to this guy, look at him.
- Please don't try to say no. (laughs)
- Mean.
- [Mark] What's the most,
what's the scariest
thing you've seen him do?
- Just walk up on somebody
and don't say anything.
- [Mark] So if one of your
tricks gives you a hard time,
starts playing games.
- Yes.
- He just walks right up on
me, he doesn't say anything.
Just his presence alone.
- [Mark] He doesn't have
to lift a finger, right?
- Nothing.
It has happened, but the scariest thing
is just watching him do nothing.
- But you respect him.
- Of course.
- [Mark] You're not forced
into staying with him.
- No.
- [Mark] You guys, you would
consider yourselves happy?
- Yeah.
- For the most part.
- But he keeps your money.
- Yes.
- And he takes care of you.
- You've seen the result.
- [Mark] Yeah, you guys look great.
How many years have you been with Joe?
- Five, maybe five years.
- Two, three years.
- So I'm the bottom..
- But there are some pimps
that you would steer away from?
- Yeah, like the ones
that wear too much jewelry
- Yes, yeah.
- Big old earrings.
- Or like, badass cars, like, mm-mm.
- [Mark] How would you
describe Joe's style?
(Joe laughs)
- Classically old school.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And his demeanor
just kind of paves the way
for everything to go smoothly, right?
- Yes.
- Strong silence.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hm.
- There's nothing nice
about Gorilla Joe, man.
Nothing. Remember, no feelings.
- No filter, either.
(both laugh)
- [Mark] What kind of
interactions have you seen
with him and some of your guys?
There's got to be some
crazy hijinks that go on
when a guy is, like, acting up
and Joe comes into the picture.
- Well I've seen him, like-
- He's hard.
- Be a chameleon, depending
on how they're acting up
is how they get treated.
Sometimes you just blend on
in, make them feel comfortable,
and then they kind of
straighten up after that
'cause, you know, power
works with something else.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And Joe, you have how many girls?
You have quite a few, right?
- Yeah, I'm at 10 right
now, working on more.
- And who's your bottom?
- Her.
- Me.
- [Mark] As a bottom
bitch, that means what?
- That I'm his main girl, so pretty much,
pretty much I'm not
retired, but I've graduated
to the level where I just keep back.
- [Mark] And you help recruit other girls?
- Yeah, get them in
line, get them dressed,
make sure they're on time.
- I'm your favorite though.
I'm her favorite, though.
- She's a work in process right here.
We're getting her right together.
- [Mark] And what do you
call the other girls?
There's a-
- Wifeys.
- Wifeys, yeah?
- Mm-hm.
- And you guys all get along?
- We do.
They have to respect me no matter what.
- Yeah.
- They got to get along in my stable.
Ain't no disruptive hos gonna
be arguing in the stable, man.
- I'm sorry?
- No disruptive hos
gonna be arguing in the stable.
- Yeah.
- This is family, you got to be, you know,
cool with each other.
- [Mark] And I'm sure one word from Joe
keeps everybody in line, right?
(Joe laughs)
- [Red] Or he just steps into the room
and everybody knows what that look means.
- [Mark] All right you guys,
thank you so much for coming in together.
- Thank you for having us.
- [Mark] And good luck
throughout the holidays.
- [Red] Thanks, happy holidays to you too.
- [Mark] Thank you very much.